Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 27th,
2014 out of what he doing.
Um,
I'm out here in Hawaii.
The day after the pro bowl,
I brought all my fucking,
I brought my mix,
I brought my chords,
I brought everything that I needed except for a God damn microphone so I can got
to do with this bootleg way,
um,
because my flight isn't until later.
And uh,
oh look who just walked in the lovely Nia.
I thought you're going to take a walk down the beach and you a little trip.
All right.
All right,
well hey,
you know,
don't let us stop you.
All right.
Enjoy yourself.
Alrighty.
So you that she walks down the Goddamn beach and I'm sitting here waving away,
which you hear a Goddamn.
Thank you.
No,
just keeping me at a great time out here.
Um,
but yeah,
our flight isn't until later on,
so
I got to do it now so I don't have a fucking microphone,
so I apologize.
Anyways,
I am out here in Hawaii.
I had a great time.
Um,
did a show Friday night and uh,
at this theater,
I remember the fucking thing,
the Hawaiian,
the Honolulu center or something like that.
It was really fucking cool,
man.
That was like a,
the Chinese New Year was going on right next door,
right down the street.
And it was fucking crazy.
It was this sort of this artsy cool and shady part of town and it was night and
they will lighten off those fireworks.
And uh,
I didn't know what it was at first and I'm like peeking around the corners,
several walking down the street go,
what the fuck is that?
And uh,
cause they will lighten off like those giant cakes of,
uh,
of firecrackers is a couple of,
you know,
Chinese dudes are walking around with the dragon outfit on night.
Was that offensive?
I don't give a fuck.
It's basically what I saw.
Um,
trying to disrespect your fucking new years.
and you know,
I grew up watching like platoon,
um,
what was the,
Whoa,
all those fucking movies there.
Uh,
what was missing in action?
All of that,
which basically just,
it was,
I don't know why agents didn't complain more in the 80 some of the fucking
movies and they made the way that they made you guys.
And that's what's funny is that stuck in my head.
I didn't think it was,
I didn't think,
it wasn't until I heard gunpowder being lid off and I was in this part of town
that had all his,
you know,
Asian look and stuff.
All of a sudden I started feeling like,
Hey,
am I going to get stuck in a bamboo cage with some rats and then get dragged out
Mau,
Mau?
Is that going to happen?
Like I was literally feeling that,
which I know to speak it out loud is ridiculous.
I guess what I'm really doing here is I'm speaking about the power of the images
that we see on television and movies.
They're corrupting our children.
Um,
I guess maybe tip a Gore had a point.
So anyways,
I went down there.
Then once I saw what was going on,
it was cool as hell.
I got to,
uh,
I'll show,
I'll actually,
I'll post the video because the video is basically me gradually discovering what
it is.
I mean,
I kind of knew as I started to,
uh,
um,
walked down towards that.
I think somebody finally had told me and uh,
but it really looks like the beginning of either some,
uh,
Oscar winning movie or some really creepy youtube video that they're going to
take down soon.
It just looks like something fucked up is about ready to happen and it's
actually a celebration.
So if you ever go down there,
white people and black people,
you know,
like what,
you understand Asians better than us.
You just as confused as we are.
Get off your fucking I yours,
when you go down there and the dragons doing all the God damn thing,
you know,
um,
when it comes over to you stick money in its mouth and that's supposed to bring
you good luck.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
I participated,
I'm on my best behavior.
I'm in a different country out here in Hawaii.
I don't give a shit what they say that this is part of America at.
This is,
it is,
but it isn't.
You know what I mean?
This is clearly some shit that we took over where I will argue with the native
Americans,
um,
till the day I die about whether or not we stole the country.
Because I got to tell you,
I look around and I see all non native Americans in the continental United
States and everybody looks pretty comfortable.
You know,
they look like they fit in like they should be there.
All right?
So I swear to God,
if one more patchy comes up to me and starts talking about how we stole the
country,
it's just like,
well then why do I look so normal up against this oak tree?
Okay,
now you take those same white people and you stick them out here in Hawaii and
we just look like we're on vacation and people are,
no,
I live here.
No,
no you don't.
No you don't.
Something happened,
something happened and somebody lost an arm cause they couldn't find the shiny
shit.
And now you have a home with that person used to have a fucking hut or some sort
of fucking thing that was made out of the ground and it was all natural,
right in the rivers were nice and clean and then we fucking showed up.
I thought it was a great moment yesterday of a,
the awfulness of,
uh,
the direction that we've had it in.
It's actually,
you know,
I'll fucking,
I'm sitting in and the upper deck of the pro bowl because I have connections
like that.
And that stadium used to be,
um,
it used to be one of those multi faceted stadiums would have multipurpose
stadiums where you played football and baseball there and you could like shift
around the stands and stuff like that and all this fucking crazy stuff.
So of course,
you know,
it rains out here,
there's all kinds of salt water in the air,
right?
So eventually everything rusts up and the thing can't fucking move anymore.
So basically they,
they welded permanently in the football position,
football position.
And,
um,
basically on each corner of the stadium,
whether it should be a corner,
you can actually look through and see out.
It's fucking hilarious.
You could see all the way from the field to the outside parking lot to the
houses in the hills,
all the way up to the mountains where it was all green and you just started at
the top and when looked all the way down to the stadium or went the other way
and you saw the,
uh,
the progress of us ruining this fucking paradise out here.
Um,
but having said that,
I actually went,
I'm going to argue,
I went to the most exciting pro bowl in recent memory yesterday in case you
missed it in case you weren't one of the 40 people will actually watch the
fucking thing.
Um,
this year,
what they did to try to add a little bit of excitement to try to get the
competitive juices flowing so people would actually fucking play the game as
opposed to playing patty cake,
patty cake and fallen down on the ground when anybody was near you.
Um,
which I totally understand why the players do it.
I mean this game does not mean shit and they're basically,
well do I want to keep making five to 10 million a year or do I want to risk
that trying to score a touchdown in this fucking game?
That doesn't matter.
Um,
what they did was they had a,
they had two team captains.
They had Jerry Rice and Deion Sanders and both of them,
they actually had a draft and they,
you know,
they pick the players and all that type of shit and it basically came down to
the end.
And uh,
there was a minute,
44 or 48 left,
most of the crowd had left.
Uh,
Tim Rice was down by seven.
And um,
I actually,
I'm not going to say I was drunk.
I was pretty,
I was feeling pretty good and I commentated the last minute,
44 weeks,
I got it all edited together in a video on the podcast page.
You got to watch it.
I'm not going to say what happens in case you missed the final outcome.
Maybe you can get excited,
get excited watching the video.
I think I did a pretty good job for being a little bit drunk,
you know,
and if you take out the curses,
I thought I held my own with a,
you know,
the gym lamp police up there.
I thought I'd done a nice job
by the way.
I also came out here.
I did a little something for I inside the NFL.
I did a little pro bono piece while I was out here and I got to talk to some of
the play and um,
I got to uh,
check out the stadium and all that type of stuff.
I'm not going to do any spoiling here,
but it's going to air this week on,
inside of the NFL on Wednesday on showtime.
All right.
And if you don't have showtime,
why don't you go order it?
I'll go find a friend that has it.
Um,
it was an unbelievable,
unbelievable week.
Uh,
yeah,
it was supposed to fucking nuts.
I don't know how to explain it.
Put it this way.
At one point,
I was actually up in the broadcast booth before the game and I got to interview
Chris Collins Worth in Al Michaels and it was just the greatest,
funniest guys and all that type of stuff.
And it just was a,
I was fucking awesome course.
I talked to Al Michaels about hockey.
Why wouldn't I,
you know,
and he had the exact opposite views I had on a lot of this stuff,
which was crushing me.
I want him to be like,
yes,
yes.
And he was just like,
no,
I feel a B and c.
He's like,
no,
D and F and I'm like,
half,
fuck.
I mean idiot.
But it was awesome.
And uh,
the game was great and I actually saw this fan,
I don't know if he's a hero or an absolute disgrace.
It to all depends on how you view,
uh,
your behavior,
right?
A game.
This fucking jerk off somehow got himself kicked out of the pro bowl.
I don't know even know how that happens.
Everybody was so well behaved and so psyched.
You're in fucking Hawaii.
The game doesn't mean anything.
Everybody's just having a great time.
This guy was such a fucking maniac and everybody else was behaving so fucking
well that I swear to God,
the entire security force for the whole fucking stadium all responded to the
call.
I've never seen that many cops.
For one guy,
they actually had,
there was like at least a half a dozen cops and two people with like those
white,
uh,
medical fucking shirts on just to kick this one idiot out.
And they finally kicked him out and he's got his tattoo chicken,
that type of shit.
And we think that gone long gone,
blah,
blah.
Which I think they kicked him out and evidently his chicks stuck around because
with like two minutes left,
this fan runs out on the field and this is what's fucking hilarious is how,
how like how much the game doesn't mean Shit.
Everybody's just sort of mentally on vacation.
I swear to God,
this woman ran around for like 50 seconds,
45,
50 seconds before anybody even knew.
Like before you saw the first security guy going out there,
they were so busy staring at the half filled stands.
They didn't know what we were yelling about.
This woman was running out of people.
She was doing that thing,
you know,
you're jumping in the air and bump into the person.
She was doing that to everybody on the field.
She was like running out of players by the time they fucking came out there and
we're looking down there with somebody falling.
It goes,
that's that fucking chick who's with the drunk guy.
So I'll,
I'll section was laughing at it and I'm,
I swear to God it took him about a minute and a half.
She started running down the field towards the other touchdown
in the place was going nuts.
Yeah,
it was a great time.
I highly,
highly recommend coming out here to the pro bowl.
It's a great,
great,
great fan experience.
Especially if the Games are going to be like they way,
the way they are now with them.
Uh,
yeah.
Picking players and stuff.
So they actually,
you know,
it,
I'm not going to lie to you,
they weren't playing the whole time,
but they will,
you know,
moments where they would,
they would,
you know,
Deon I guess was talking to the camera.
I didn't see that part,
but was like going,
that's not going to be like this and eat,
amp them up and they'd play for a couple,
uh,
you know,
for the rest of the fucking quarter or something like that.
But at the end of it,
who gives a fuck?
You were in Hawaii.
So anyways,
sorry for the fucking man right here.
What am I up to here?
12 minutes.
Okay.
Oh,
I got it.
I forgot to tell you this.
I'm sorry if I'm speaking a little too quietly here cause I'm in my hotel room
and they can't be screaming cunt and my hotel.
Um,
so anyways,
they actually had all like all the mascots or majority of them.
I didn't see the Patriots,
stupid Paul Revere,
whatever the fuck that guy's supposed to be mascots at the pro bowl.
So I wasn't really paying attention,
but at one point all the fucking mascots are in the end zone.
Okay.
And they have like a little card with a letter on both sides,
which I think,
you know,
they all line up in it.
It says welcome to the pro bowl and then they turn it over a police support the
troops,
whatever the fuck it's spelled out.
So it was one of those deals,
they spelled something,
then they flipped it over and it's spelled something else.
And then they were done,
the camera shot was done and then they just all sort of started to separate
in three mascots,
randomly got together and for five seconds for standing in the end zone spelling
out Jew.
It was one of the funniest fucking things I ever saw.
And what's killed me was how many people missed it cause everybody,
cause they went down to the right hand side and the ball was down in the left.
It was like a TV time out or something.
So they was spelling out some fucking thing for the fans and they went back the
other way.
And I had interviewed a couple of the fucking mascots,
so I was kind of just watching that little shtick.
Okay.
And um,
me and the people we were with sought and Oma,
God fucking dying,
dying,
laughing.
If I,
if I had a picture of that,
that would have been the funniest shit ever.
You know,
that's where those Nazis has been hiding all these years.
Everybody's been looking for him down in South America and fucking Brazil.
They've been hiding in plain sight dressing up as huggable fucking Baltimore
Ravens.
I forget.
I want to rat anybody else.
But the Raven Guy was part of it.
I think he was holding up the w uh,
oh my God,
that was,
can you think of anything less antisemetic than a fucking mask off?
It's just supposed to be this lovable thing doing the worm and the fucking
Moonwalk,
getting people going.
Right.
Sticking your fucking head and its mouth.
Then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
you just see this ugly side of this thing.
It was so fucking this,
like why,
if he just took it seriously,
like why would a mascot hate Jewish people?
And I love that there was no point.
It just said Ju
oh shit and out,
whatever.
It was fucking funny to me.
Let me read some advertising here.
Christ.
Where the hell Lowery?
All right,
here we go.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Dollar Shave Club.
Okay.
For a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing quality razors right to your front door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudge into the drug store for a pack of blades.
All right?
I always get stuck behind some meth kid trying to,
you know,
buy a frigging toothbrush for this one tooth he has left in his head,
right?
But now with dollar shave club for just a couple of bucks a month,
amazing quality razors.
They delivered right to your door.
That's right.
No more wasting your time and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks every time you
go to buy razors.
Everybody here meaning me is getting their dollar shave club blades and you know
what?
You should too.
Come on Phi.
Jumped off a bridge.
You do it to one year,
we'll get your damn plagues.
He is a genius idea.
Tribe.
Replacing your old shaving cream with Dr Carver's.
Easy Shave five from dollar shave club.com trust me,
your face will thank you later.
If it could speak and could think independently,
uh,
don't waste time at the drug store behind the lady paying at Penney's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash bar or go to billboard.com and Click
on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low and your bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward slash bar.
There you go.
Look at that.
That was a nice,
even fucking par.
I didn't go into the water.
I didn't go into the fucking sand.
Nothing.
All right,
let's try this next one.
Why do I fucking feel like I have a cold?
But I don't.
All right.
Nature's box.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Nature his box.
I swear to God.
This is what it's called.
We're talking about are too wide over there.
Uh,
nature.
Nature's box going to be a professional nature's box.
Everyone curbing your appetite doesn't get any easier just because you went on a
diet.
When 3:00 PM hunger pangs hit,
you can,
you can tough it out and get cranky and lightheaded or you can hit the vending
machine and pack on the pounds.
But now there's a third option.
Snacks smarter in 2014 with nature's box.
Go down on this box of goodies is that,
this is joke.
This can't be true.
Sign up to nature's box for great tasting,
healthy snacks sent right to your door or nature box.
It's not nature as box.
Okay,
now I get it.
Sign up to nature box.
Excuse me.
For great tasting healthy snacks sent right to your door.
Well,
why don't you leave it at the end of the driveway.
So we've burned a few more calories and I'm not talking about rabbit food.
Think French toast,
Granola,
salted Caramel,
Pretzel pops and dark cocoa almonds and more designed to leave you full and
healthy.
Check it out.
now@naturebox.com you'll find zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup and nothing artificial.
And Nature's box ships for free,
just like nature does.
Okay.
Right now,
try your first order of naturebox@fiftypercentoffbygoingtonaturebox.com slash
[inaudible] that's naturebox.com/bar stop the vending machine madness.
Snatch smarter in 2014 getting a handle on your health and your hunger.
Go to nature.
box.com/burr
okay?
No.
What do they have?
Their salted Caramel Pretzel pops.
I'm going to lose weight.
Dark cocoa almonds.
Okay.
French toast granola.
Okay,
so let's see the scam here.
There's no trans fats.
There's no high fructose corn syrup.
How about nutrition?
Is there any nutrition in that shit?
Yeah,
Jesus.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't I get full Eaton Carmel,
Pretzel Pops,
you death,
whatever.
stamps.com everybody.
Hey,
if you haven't heard yet,
posted rates have changed.
Again,
you know what that means.
The post office is even more crowded than usual.
That's why you need stamps.com with stamps.com you can assimilate and eliminate
those time consuming trips to the post office.
Everything you can do at the post office you can do right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package using your own
computer or printer and stamps.com always updates the postage rates for you
automatically so you don't even have to think baby,
so you'll always get the exact postage you need,
the incident you need it.
You'll never have to go to the post office again unless you're dating someone
over there.
I've been using stamps.com for the last couple of years.
It's so convenient,
so easy.
Even a moron like me can do it right now.
Use My last name.
Burpee you are are for the special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to 55
bucks free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
let the baby cry.
Get on this.
Click on the microphone at the top of the page,
the homepage and type in bur bur that stamps.com enter burr.
Okay,
well,
I don't know about you guys,
but I think I just crushed those reads the nature of box people are probably
upset with me,
but I,
you know,
some,
I don't give a shit.
I hate when they do that stuff.
Well,
nature's nature box,
like this is really healthy.
You know,
there's no trans fats that's like you fucking,
you know,
drinking yourself to death and you're going,
well,
you know,
there's no heroine,
no heroin in this shit.
Um,
this probably be the last week for that reason.
You know,
out of fucking what are you gonna do?
Okay,
let's get back to,
let's get back to the podcast.
Oh,
this week I finally announced,
um,
after three people on the Internet were clamoring going,
when are you good?
Announced your Canadian tour.
We actually had the presale on Wednesday of last week and it officially went on
sale on Friday and I have to take time to thank the entire almost set continent,
the entire country of Canada for the unbelievable response.
Oh,
Canada,
you bought a bunch of tickets.
So we add,
it shows four rolled red phase,
twinkle toes.
I'm going to break my jokes and a shiny shirt.
I'll do my act for you.
Hey,
you know what kills me is if you saw some of the fucking godforsaken places that
I'm going on on this Canadian tour.
All right.
You would think that all Canadians would be happy that I didn't just go to
Montreal,
Toronto,
and they'd go to Vancouver and then just say,
oh,
hey,
I toured Canada.
I'm going to Vancouver,
Edmonton,
Calgary,
Winnipeg,
Toronto,
someplace,
Hamilton.
I,
you know where the fuck that is?
MMM.
Ottawa.
Montreal.
I'm going to Nova Scotia,
I think Halifax.
Is that what that does?
That?
That's where it is.
You would think they'd be like,
wow,
thanks bill.
Thanks for the fucking effort.
You'd think everybody would say that,
but no.
Only 98% of Canadians.
Yeah.
Okay.
Was that where,
where would that thankful?
Then I got another 2% that were giving me shit because I skipped over
Saskatchewan.
Okay.
Right.
I want to win a too.
Yeah.
Hey,
people in Saskatchewan,
I appreciate the interest,
but you have a fucking stop for two seconds.
You ever think of rather than just looking at your fucking Igloo,
you may be try and look and see where I'm coming from.
I live in Los Angeles.
Okay.
Do you think I have time to go to every God damn province up there?
I'm going out of five.
Five.
You got 10 provinces out there.
I'll go into five out of 10 of them.
Why can't you see that?
The syrup bucket is half full.
Okay.
You know I live in Los Angeles.
I have fake titties to look at and I'm taking time on a Mike.
Nice sunny fucking winter to go up to that fucking most to step around most
shit.
All right?
Okay.
For most of the months of March.
And you're going to give me shit because I'm not going to Newfoundland.
I'm not going to Saskatchewan.
Why don't you get in your fucking pickup truck and drive over one province?
Help me out.
Help me help you.
Can you do that?
I'm just fucking with the,
actually,
uh,
I heard your complaints and because I'm a people pleaser,
I'm actually talking to my agent right now and we're seeing what we can do.
All right.
If I have time or I can fucking put another one in there,
you know,
rather than take a day off and get drunk and go curling or maybe play some pond
hockey and do something that I wanted to do,
you know,
go up there and hang out with the Celine Dion Hall of fame.
Something that I would've found enjoyable.
I'm actually looking into my schedule.
Okay.
To see if I can make it to those fucking places and you know,
it's funny.
I'll add those and then some con,
the Yukon territory is going to give me shit.
You know what,
I'm never going to get off the road.
Hey,
here's a fucking question I have for you.
Okay.
All right.
When you're flying internationally,
all right.
For New fucking international flyers out there,
when you're going from like,
okay,
say like the Olympics Olympics,
so like,
or what Moscow this year,
I know they're in the Ukraine.
They always fly up.
If you're flying from the states,
they fly you up by Greenland and they go up to the top of the globe,
also known as North,
you know,
cause it should conferences or lunch shorter up there.
Right.
And you fly over there so they can save gas and you don't run out and fall into
the fucking ocean.
I get that.
Here's my question.
Why don't they have it just go up and over.
Just go right up and over.
Yeah.
Say if you want to go to Moscow,
if it's bay or Beijing and it's on the opposite side of the world,
why don't you just get in a plane in Chicago and flied due north and go right up
and over the fucker.
You watch a couple of movies and you're there.
Okay.
How was asking this question as I always do a to non pilots because I love to
hear what non pilots have to say about flying and then take their information
and presented as fact to a other people who aren't in the aviating field.
Um,
what does it have to do with the magnetic poles of the planet?
That's it.
Fuck.
With the,
yeah,
you're a little fucking rotisseries there on the fucking dashboard and all of a
sudden you don't know where the ground is and where the sky is.
You know what exactly is the problem?
United Airlines.
Why can't you just fly up and over?
Okay.
Or down in under from my friends down there in Argentina.
Yeah.
In Australia.
Why can't they do that with a fuck?
Would you go then?
Hey,
when you fly,
you know.
Okay.
If,
when you fly over Antarctica,
is there a point where you're just upside down?
I'm
sorry,
that was only 80% joking.
Um,
all right,
so here's,
here's a,
here's a video.
Here's a video of that that a lot of people sent me this week.
It was about these,
uh,
these fucking bank,
a cock suck.
Is there,
um,
let's see,
what letter is it here?
This isn't the BBC news.
Uh,
HSBC imposes restrictions on large cash withdrawals.
All right.
And uh,
so at HSBC,
customers have been prevented.
Some customers have ever been prevented from withdrawing large amounts of cash
because they could not provide evidence of why they wanted it to.
BBC has learnt,
isn't it?
Learned,
has learnt anyways.
Listeners have told radios for his money box,
not to be confused with nature's box.
They were stopped from withdrawing amounts ranging from five grand of 5,000
pounds,
10,000 pounds.
HSBC admitted it is not informed.
Customers have to change in policy policy,
which was implemented in November.
The bank says it is now changed its guidance to staff.
Um,
so basically,
okay,
this guy went down,
they said,
can I have my 5,000 pounds that I earned and I put in this bank for safety?
They said no.
He said,
can I have 4,000 pounds?
They said no.
And then I wrote one out,
I guess one of the withdrawal slip for 3000 pounds.
And they said,
okay,
we'll give you that.
Um,
blah,
blah.
So they got a bunch of bad press and how allegedly they're changing it.
So a bunch of people said,
you know,
what's the fucks with these banker con?
You know,
it's,
it's our money,
Yada,
Yada and all that shit.
I got news for you.
It's not your money.
All right.
It's their money.
They print it,
it's theirs,
okay?
And your job is to take the money that they give you for working your ass off
all week,
and your job is to then take that money and give it back to them or get your ass
into debt with it.
Okay?
Think about your work all fucking weekend.
What do I do?
Even hold money in your fucking hand anymore.
They give it to you on this fucking piece of paper,
all right?
I know a lot of people rolling their eyes right now,
okay?
But I got to point at the end of this shit.
Okay?
You take it down to these fuckers.
Just
give it to them.
Now this is the thing,
the reason why it's not like the reason why they didn't give that person the
10,000 pounds.
Do you know why they didn't give it to them?
It's because they don't have it.
Okay?
I'm not saying that they don't physically have 10,000 pounds in the back.
Yes they do,
but they don't have 10,000 pounds available to give to it.
Just some random jackass who goes,
oh,
by the way,
I want to take 10,000 pounds out right fucking now they don't have it.
Well,
I dunno about how it works in England,
but as far as in the United States,
they don't have it for the simple fact that when,
yeah,
if you went and you deposit some regular fucking Tom,
Dick,
Harry or Louise and you deposit 10 grand into a bank,
back in the old days when there was some sort of rules and regulations governing
these audit control cons,
when you ran a bank,
you had on your books,
like you can only loan out a certain percentage of the money
or the bank was in violation.
Like,
like saying,
let's just say to make it easy,
there are million dollars was deposited into your bank.
You could only at during that time you could only loan out,
I don't know what the percentage was,
but it was like 300 grand of it,
400 grand.
Um,
I forget what the percentage was,
but she,
you could,
you couldn't go past a certain tipping point because God forbid if there was a
run on money and everybody started withdrawing,
the bank would fail.
Now any bag,
if everybody shows up and tries to take the money out is gonna fail because you
know,
they,
they loan out a certain percentage of it all right?
But throughout the years they kept pushing that percentage up more and more and
more and more to the point that they got up to not only can they loan out 100%
of the deposits from the hard work and the people that deposit the money in
there,
they can actually then create another $2 million off that million,
something like that.
Like,
so if you deposit 10 grand,
they can take your full 10 grand loan it out plus another 10 grand off that 10
grand plus another 10 grand off that 10 grand.
So they basically just invented slash counterfeited 20 grand.
That didn't even fucking exist off that 10 grant.
They got 30 grand loaned out so they can make the money off that fucking 20%
interest off of that kick and you half a percent in your fucking account and
they just sit there knowing full well at some point whatever bubble they're
creating is going to burst.
Shit is going to hit the fan.
You're going to be asked out and they're too big to fail.
And at worst case scenario that you're going after a corporation and what are
they?
They're just,
they're just,
they're faceless corporation is faceless.
They take their bonuses.
It's just sitting there waiting for John Cougar Mellencamp to write you a
fucking song.
It fucking jackass aid and they're out there buying a new fucking yacht.
All right.
Did that make sense?
And I know you guys are going to be a girl.
You full of Shit,
blah blah,
blah blah.
You don't know what the fuck you talking about.
You sound like a moron.
Hey,
I'll take all of that.
But I'm going to tell you this for like the fucking hundredth time in my standup
career when I was in Albuquerque,
I had a banker come up to me and was laughing going,
I know you hate us.
And I said,
listen,
am I a moron and the podcast?
And they always say no.
They go,
no,
you're not.
You know this of some factual errors a little bit here or there.
But basically what you're saying is 100% true.
I talked conspiracy theory one time in my own bank as I was trying to set
something up new on my account.
I was talking to a banker about conspiracy theory and he was talking about
banking.
It was talking about how scary and fucked up it was.
And he was asking me what I plan to do.
What do you think about gold and silver coins?
What are you think about growing Zucchini?
And I,
it was the most techniques whispering and shit.
I'm telling you.
Um,
and I have no solution.
So when I'm really being right now was the fucking fearmonger.
But,
uh,
this is,
this is the great thing about banking is that,
you know,
I would say a good 95% of people walking around with a fucking Goddamn tootsie
pop in their mouth,
pulling their fucking Hawaiian shorts out of their ass,
crack,
believe in it.
All right?
And as long as they continue to believe in it,
you can kind of exist in the game drafting behind there.
Um,
uninformed.
I don't know what the fucking words,
I'm too stupid to do this,
but you just basically like,
I dunno,
I am of the belief that if you can get a fucking house by one that you can
afford and then pay that fucker down as soon as you can.
And all of that shit that people say where they go,
oh no,
invest investment because you go to the dude,
fuck that.
Pay Off your fucking house.
And then if the bank fails,
you still have a house.
Who gives a fuck if you paid 700 grand for it,
now it's only worth a hundred grand.
You still have a house.
As much as that sucks,
at least just still have it.
Like the fucking stock market,
right?
You work your whole God damn life.
You stick it in that and stick it in this over there when you think you're being
conservative,
the thing shits the bed and in the end you can be left with nothing.
So I am into tangent,
tangible shit.
Can you tell?
He screamed whenever I do a podcast the day after I went to a game or I did a
lot of shows.
I sound like I'm going through puberty again.
I apologize.
But um,
I believe in investing in tangible shift.
And don't let your wife or your husband be local.
We go,
kid,
we'd go,
we'd go to shave up with a college education.
You know what?
Fuck their college education.
All right.
Take out a loan.
Take out a fucking look.
You're paying interest on your house.
Now the amount of money that you're going to save knocking down your principal
will pay for most if not all of their college education.
All right?
Unless they just go to some unbelievably expensive school.
And your,
I dunno,
living in some little house on the prairie,
I'm like a land and smoking a pipe.
Um,
so there you go.
So that's why,
that's why when they go down there,
because they,
they're not going to give 10 grand or 10 pounds to the average jackass walking
in there because that starts fucking with their game,
which is pretending that all the money is there and that it's,
it's safe and that there's nothing to worry about and nothing to see here.
So what they do is they pull this shit and they bullied people individually over
in the corner behind that bulletproof glass.
And they're like,
no,
you have to get a note.
And blahblahblahblahblah.
And most people,
like they have a parent child relationship their entire life.
They come out as a child,
their parents tell them what to do,
what they can and can't do,
when they can eat,
when they have to go to bed and they go off into the world,
you know,
you go to school,
we'll go to lunch,
now you have a question,
raise your hand and you,
you stay in that mentality.
So to the point you have a fucking adult who earned the money will go into a
bank.
You know,
God bless this person who actually fucking was like,
no,
this is my money and complained and brought this out to light.
But do you think this is the only person they did that?
So
the money's not there man.
Yeah.
Like if you had like two 300 grand in an account and you decide that you just
want to fucking take it out.
Like if you physically want the money,
if you want to transfer it,
like fucking numbers,
hit enter,
they'll fucking do that all day.
I had no worries.
But if you actually wanted the paper,
like you can't just walk in there and be like,
yes,
I'd like my 300 grant and they'd be like,
oh,
okay.
And come out big sex and money.
You got to call them days if not a week in advance.
And then what they gotta do is frantically call around and find an armored car
with enough of this paper that isn't worth shit other than the fact that the guy
with the underwear and his ass still believes in it.
They got to drive that there so they can physically keep the lie going.
Alright,
there you go.
So that's the end of my,
my fucking a barroom banking one oh one.
All right.
And uh,
you know,
I don't give a fuck about your opinions either because I'm not enlightened as a
human being.
If you don't agree with what I said,
then you know,
just laugh at me and continue on with your fucking day because a,
you're actually helping me out as long as you keep fucking believing in it
minute.
But I think the day the wave hitting the beach is coming soon because,
uh,
you know,
at least in this country,
I mean the government shut down for three fucking days and I know it made for
great standup material,
but that is absolutely fucking terrifying.
Every year when August comes around and we hit the debt ceiling and we just keep
raising it,
we just keep pushing more of shit under the bed.
Like eventually,
it's not all,
I dunno,
that's probably the wrong analogy.
I don't what the fuck we're doing,
but eventually the shit is going to hit the fan.
So,
uh,
I'm not saying I'm going to survive it,
whatever the fuck happens,
but I do have a game plan.
My game plan is to pay off my house as quickly as I can.
So when the first wave of people are being brought to the,
uh,
I dunno what euphemism they're going to be using for that
detention camps.
Um,
I figured it'll be like,
but you can't pay off your house for repossessing the house.
So now we're going to move you to alternative,
relaxing,
living,
whatever the fuck they're going to call it.
At least I won't be in that first wave of people.
I will have my house paid off and I was standing there dressed like a court
gesture with my little fancy cane.
Okay.
Going but get off my property and they'll look at me and be like,
oh,
look at those little cut thick and he has power.
All right,
we'll be back for you.
We'll be back for like a month to salt.
Let's just get the,
uh,
let's get the mouth breathers first.
Let's get the easy people then will weed out the red conch and then it'll all be
ours.
Some of that somehow ties in to how they're trying to make robots more and more
human link.
All right,
this is the kind of Shit,
this story right here
that seems like a victory for the common man.
And what it really is,
is this just moving the ball forward on the development of robots so they can
eventually phase us out.
Um,
and then they can just have robot people that will never,
never complain.
And then of course,
if you watch science fiction movies,
they somehow take over the humans,
which they're not going to do.
They're not going to do that.
All right?
We made you all right,
we'll unplug you.
We won't fix.
You have dump some water on you.
You know,
this is the deal.
Every fucking web designer when he builds your website or build you a secure
site always builds in a fucking back door.
All right?
So the guys making the robots are going to do the same fucking thing.
There's no way the Illuminati is going to have a bunch of robots that are
stronger than them.
Don't need to sleep and all that type of shit.
And like they watch science fiction movies.
These fuckers are science fiction.
How crazy do I sound this week?
I'm actually enjoying every fucking second of this.
Um,
they're going to have a back door,
you know,
somewhere up that robots ask this gotta be something that they can fucking do.
Some button they have to push.
Um,
all right,
so they got,
was that weird enough for you?
Huh?
I'm sorry.
What do you,
what do you want from me?
You know,
I'm a fucking weird guy.
Some more.
Let me,
let me bring it back to earth with a fucking commercial.
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everyone.
You know,
some things like starting your own business or protecting your family with a
will aren't like your other new year's resolutions.
You can't afford to blow them off.
Instead of less snacking and more exercise,
put those things to the agile is set at the top of your list.
I still think that that's written incorrectly.
That's why I tried to Improv.
Improv my way through that legal zone helps you in court what they're really
trying to say.
Instead of watching your waistline and exercise and what you're great things you
might want to consider having a will.
All right?
In case you get hit by a bus,
you know when somebody takes you all the stuff off your mantle and your kids
don't get it instead of why whatever.
Over a 1 million entrepreneurs have done it in 90% of customers.
Recommend legal zoom to friends and family.
You can also create a will starting at just $69 or even a even a living trust
quickly and easily and get peace of mind and protection.
No surprise fees,
no hassles,
man,
no headaches.
Legal Zoom step by step process was created by a team of experts in law and
technology.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm but can connect you with the third party attorney
and provide you with self help services for wells to business formations,
trademarks,
powers of attorney and more.
Go to legal zoom.com for even more savings.
Type in burpee.
You rr into the referral box at checkout.
Don't put off things you need to do today.
Go to legalzoom.com now and use the discount code bur bur that's legalzoom.com
discount code bar.
Oh Geez.
I'm just hitting the fairways today guys.
I'm not saying I'm not to Putin,
but I'm doing it right here.
All right,
he voice you are a business owner but autumn,
but an automated phone system and secretaries are not in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls yourself,
it makes it pretty hard to look like a professional.
Right?
Well,
here's something that will drastically help or dramatically help you more with
my uh,
with your money in 2014.
It's a voice.
Everybody,
whether you're a business of one or 100 he voice will help you manage all of
your incoming calls with a toll free number,
dial by name,
directory and call routing tools.
Your business will sound like 1 million bucks.
He can't take the call,
no problem.
Eve Voice.
We'll transcribe the voicemail and email it right to you.
Never be caught off guard again.
And with he voice you can try it before you buy it right now.
Just for my listeners,
you can get a 60 day trial to he voice absolutely free.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo code bill at checkout.
Take a check.
Sorry.
Take charge of your business and make more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and enter bill at checkout for your 60 day free trial.
That's [inaudible] dot com promo code built.
You know,
I fucked up there in the ending because I could swear to God that nature box was
really bothering me.
You know,
I'm going to talk to those guys.
I'm going to find out more about what they're putting in nature's box there
because I'm not going to sell you guys a bunch of shit that's not even healthy
for you,
but you know that's looks like one of those fad diet.
You know what?
You just eat a fucking banana.
Okay,
Laurie,
what is a banana?
25 cents 35 cents in New York with a 50 cents.
Now gives a fuck.
Eat a God damn banana.
Have an apple,
it's fiber.
It's going to fill you up.
Have a giant salad.
You know what you need to do and you're just being lazy.
And rather than doing that,
okay,
cause your body's craving sugar and salt,
you think in that you want to eat fucking Carmel Pretzel Cupcakes,
whatever the fuck they're selling,
you don't.
What you need to do is you need to fucking do.
You need,
they get a goddamn salad.
You need to get that in your body and then your body will crave that.
Your body will crave nutrition and it's the greatest fucking thing ever.
And if you actually read up on nutrition,
which I have only kind of done and it's helped me immensely,
but if you guys,
you know,
there's no way you're gonna be dumber than I am.
If you actually read up on nutrition,
you don't even fucking,
if you go for walks,
you don't need to go to the gym.
If you just did pushups and pull ups and you ate a balanced nutrition diet,
nutrition,
nutritional diet,
you know what?
The goddamn fucking
snicker doodle that looks like a chocolate color covered fucking apple.
I hate that shit.
All right.
I just have a bio of fucking old roommate of mine used to do that all the time
and you'll know who it is by the impression,
you know?
No,
I'm not going to do it,
but this first,
some used to fucking go on these God used to one time he was on this diet,
drinking like this chocolate shake three times a day.
Three times a fucking day.
This dude is drinking a goddamn chocolate shake to lose weight.
Oh,
it's chocolate.
Favorite fucking powder.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure that's not,
I'm sure that's great for your waistline,
but I can imagine that's doing something else fucked up.
Would you look at what you're,
you're putting in your body.
You fucking moron us.
It's just,
and I'm more on what are you,
what are you going to do?
Hey,
you know,
Drake,
you fucking powdered milk.
I don't give a shit die sooner.
And uh,
you know the rivers are cleaner.
All right,
where do I go from here?
Oh,
last week.
You know what?
I forgot to bring up.
I had such a busy week.
Um,
I went to the,
uh,
hang on a second here.
What the fuck did I just do there?
Okay.
I gotta make sure.
Oh,
all right.
Hang on a second.
I know it sounds weird right now.
I gotta look this up here.
Make sure I get this right and get the dates right and everything.
Um,
all right.
Last week I forgot to mention,
okay,
that I went to the,
uh,
now why the fuck motor come out now?
Could now it comes up.
All right.
This happens once a week on the podcast.
If you new to it,
by the way,
I always go to look something up and of course my computer doesn't even fucking
work.
Um,
anyways,
I went to the,
uh,
the common thread clinic tour,
which is a drum clinic for all your drummers out there.
If you just want to watch three absolute fucking beast on the drums with three
totally styles.
Um,
and what's really cool is they're actually all seven years apart.
That's what they said once 23,
one's 30,
one's 37.
And,
um,
it was just an absolutely incredible tour that I ended up going to because I was
following Mike Johnston,
who I've talked about here,
Mike's lessons.com.
And,
uh,
he's on tour with Matt Halpern and a JP Bouvier.
I hope I said that right.
Fluent French for so many God damn years.
Absolutely amazing.
Um,
amazing,
amazing drummers.
So as far as the tour that I see,
uh,
it looks like they're off right now,
but they're gonna maybe start back up in April of I'm saying this right.
Um,
you can look it up on Facebook.
The common thread clinic tour,
April 18th,
19th 20th 22 2125 they go,
this was basically there'll be Lancaster,
Pennsylvania on the 18th.
Uh,
they're going to be in debt for township,
New Jersey on April 19th,
Asbury Park,
New Jersey on the 20th.
Manhattan,
New York,
Sam Ash,
the 22nd,
uh,
Middletown New York on the 23rd Manhattan New York drummers collective.
April 25th.
I used to take drum lessons there,
places.
Awesome.
Anyways,
um,
if you're a drummer or even just a musician,
like they gave just great advice on how to get better and how to actually make a
living as a musician was absolutely fucking mind blowing.
Amazing.
Um,
drum clinic.
And one of the coolest things is all three of them are up there at the same
time.
So they kind of draw out of a hat who's going to solo first.
And one of the coolest thing other than listening and watching the drum solo is
watching the other two drummers watching who's ever playing.
And you watch them learning stuff and kind of looking at each other smiling when
they see whatever cool Phil or something like that.
It was,
it was fucking awesome.
Can't say enough great things about it.
So,
uh,
you know,
we'll have the link up on the podcast page for the common thread,
a clinic tour.
Hope you guys get to check it out or he just like fucking drums.
You know,
it works on so many levels.
Do you want to make a dream come true?
It actually works on that fucking level.
Um,
if you know how to just apply it.
And what kills me about watching these guys getting better,
talking about getting better as drummers,
this,
it's the exact same like process as getting to get better as a,
uh,
a comedian or even like an athlete,
you know,
finding a weakness,
working on a weakness,
you know,
sticking with it,
being open and be a positive networking with the people.
It's the all the same,
the exact same thing.
It was really fucking mind blowing.
So,
uh,
check it out if you get a chance.
And with that we are one week away,
not even one week away from the super bowl everybody.
And um,
I actually thought that all they were going to do is talking about Sherman Guy
and uh,
evidently I guess all they've been talking about is the weather.
I don't,
you know,
I haven't been paying attention,
but uh,
you know,
I did that thing this week and I talked to a lot of football guys and people
just kept bringing up the weather.
I don't understand what is the big fucking deal that it's in New York City
football fans.
Like,
I don't understand.
Why are they tough?
Right up until the,
the AFC and NFC championship games and they could sit and snow.
You know,
did anybody die at the Green Bay packer game?
It was like fucking minus 20 whatever it was.
It was fine.
They're football fans.
Why are they making such a big fucking deal if it snows and the Superbowl and
you know what it is for what I've heard,
it's because so many fucking haberdashery cons who don't even give a fuck these
corporate people that want to show up in their wing tips in there fucking ties,
you know,
and he fucking Sushi and all that shit during the game.
That's the big deal.
Cause I was sitting there thinking like this is fucking great.
The one of the great NFL films of all time is when they show a,
that Greenbay Dallas cowboys game up in Lambeau field,
the frozen Tundra,
right?
People are going to be fine.
There's no problem.
Stop acting like regular people are nervous about a little bit of fucking snow.
I think it's going to be great.
It's about time.
Why do they always get to play around a bunch of palm trees?
I fucking,
you know something.
I fucking hate the Superbowl.
I love that it's for the championship,
but I hate all of how much more shit can add to it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Now one band,
you've got two bands.
You've got all this stupid commercials,
you know,
I said last week to just let the game go.
Like take the game,
let it go.
90 minutes before you start.
I would actually go a full two hours this year with all of the Goddamn crap that
I'm a grumpy old man.
All right,
let's plow forward.
Um,
and somebody give that Guy Sherman a hug.
Okay.
I know he's acting all confident in everything,
but I'm telling you,
that guy needs a hug.
He needs a hug and please tell him that he's the best.
Everything in the world.
I'll call it it right now.
Call her right now.
That guy will eventually break down and cry in an interview.
He's going to,
there will be the softer side of,
uh,
whatever his first name is Sherman.
I swear to God,
I seen him before.
I called it when I saw a rex Ryan walking around,
stick it out as fucking is man.
Tits talking all this shit.
I'm telling you,
that guy cries himself to sleep with a bowl of ice cream.
You know,
his wife rubs his head every night telling him it's,
it's going to be okay.
I'm just fucking with rex riding.
I actually think he's a great coach and he asks you,
he hasn't talked any shit in a couple of years,
but he hasn't had a team where he could.
So I think it's very easy for him to be behaving himself.
So we'll see.
Who the fuck knows what [inaudible] judge him.
Right.
All right.
Okay.
Let's get with into the emails for the week.
Paul Pierce's returned to Boston,
a Billy leaf clover.
I just left the TD bank north Gatton.
Not sure if you had any hotels,
sports center time whilst in Hawaii,
but peers made is returned tonight.
It was really special.
The consensus was that no one,
no other Boston athlete has received as warm.
A welcome is pierce would,
uh,
having been there,
I got to say it's the truth.
No Pun intended.
Men were crying.
Kids who didn't grow up watching,
watching him knew he was something special,
by the way.
It felt in there tonight.
No one played harder night after night for over a decade.
And even while,
no,
even while no one was watching Tuesday night games against the raptors at the
end of a losing,
losing season and he would still play his heart out.
It was really amazing.
The link is below,
uh,
for the video from the game actually watched it.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
A Celtics fan traded him right when he came back.
Um,
yeah.
I mean that reminded me of the standing ovation that Bobby your got when he came
back,
when Larry Bird a retired.
I mean,
that was right up there with,
um,
with everybody.
And I think that's such a great thing when fans,
uh,
show their appreciation like that.
So I'm psyched.
It seemed like obviously Paul Pierce was really moved and that type of thing,
and he's definitely,
he's going to be up there.
They're,
I think they're going to retire as number they have to.
They have to.
He's one of the great,
so,
uh,
if you didn't get a chance,
we'll have that link.
I got alarmed.
I'm promising a lot of links this week.
Everybody.
Okay.
Did I mention that I,
yeah,
I mentioned that I commentated the last minute 45 of the pro bowl.
That's the one I'm,
I'm looking forward to hearing your reaction to because,
uh,
I'm about me,
not Paul Pierce.
I'm a selfish shit and Taina.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
Bill,
my friend wants to be you,
dear freckled avenger.
I have a problem.
Ever since one of my buddies started listening to you,
he started trying to act exactly like you.
He started using a fake Boston accent.
He changes as appending pinions according to the weekly podcast.
I know because I listened to the show and I can hear his opinions changed during
our conversations on Tuesday morning.
Also,
he roots for all Boston sports teams.
Now,
the only thing he hasn't done his dies fucking hair red.
I don't want to be the asshole.
I don't want to be the asshole calls them out of ruins the friendship.
Could you please say a few words about this?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Well listen pal,
you know it's long been stated that I am the Taylor swift of podcasting,
right?
Little boys and girls look up to me.
They want to be me.
They play dress up.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do with this fucking email.
Whatever.
He seems like he's enjoying it to another level.
I liked that.
He's a fan of all Boston teams right now and I'm kind of enjoying that.
It's ruining your life.
I actually wish I didn't read this.
I wonder if he's listening right now and can actually tell that your,
his own friend wrote this.
This is fucking weird.
I'm right in the middle of it.
Um,
is he going to get a fucking Patriots Jersey that says freckled to venture on
the back of it?
No.
Okay.
And what kind of friend to you?
Man.
Why?
Why can't you just let him have his fun?
People need heroes.
Why can't I be a hero to somebody?
You know?
You know what I want to do.
I want that dude to come out to a comedy show.
When he laughs at one of my jokes,
I want to do that Taylor swift thing and I'll look over and his direction and
I'll just whisper,
did you ever see that thing on 60 minutes?
Would she,
she would look into the upper deck,
what all these girls were screaming and she would get this weird look on her
face and then she would whisper,
oh my God.
And it was just this total calculated thing to try and make it appear that she
was so blown away by their,
uh,
show of affection.
But what it really seemed like
the look on her face.
And then the fact she was saying,
Oh my God,
she actually looked like,
okay.
She looked like she was thinking like,
I thought I already killed those little bastards.
They're back again.
Yeah.
I,
you have to fucking poison them again.
Um,
but there you go.
Everybody.
I have my first,
I'm
single.
Yeah.
What is it?
Single white male.
Maybe we'll do a remake of the movie.
Hey,
you know what?
In that movie.
That chick was a red hat,
right?
Not Jesus.
Alright.
Dutch girlfriend turns out to be a hawk.
Griffin.
Oh Man,
I feel bad for you,
but I don't feel bad for you provided you didn't get an STD and you didn't knock
her up.
Oh,
Jesus.
All right,
let's put on some latex and wade into this one.
Everybody dear bill,
I live in the Netherlands.
Um,
I've been casually seeing this girl for a few months.
Her family is rich.
She's a pro fashion model and it looks like Brigitte Bardot.
I've heard that name,
but I can't picture the face with a name like that.
Right?
She's gotta be all stuck up.
Huh?
Was there fucking perfect jeans?
Anyways,
yesterday she told me that for the past few months she's been working as a
whore.
How fucked up my mind that actually find that sexy on some level.
Um,
high class on account of her looks and profession.
2000 euros for three hours.
10,000 euros for 24 hours.
Oh my God.
Some guys slobbered all over you for 10,000 hours.
How quickly did you have to break up with this girl?
I shouldn't make fun of this.
This is terrible.
Why?
Why is she tapping out?
She's taking the easy way out here.
Yeah.
You're already a model.
Everybody's rich.
Is she getting written out of the will?
Okay.
She's freaking out like what do I do?
I've been rich my whole life.
Dot.
I'm not going to be,
oh,
suck it.
Oh,
well,
why do I read when I continue reading here?
The usual clientele is rich corporate assholes and idiots who save up and think
paying ludicrous amounts of money.
We'll get them a better orgasm.
I have absolutely no interest in seeing this girl anymore.
She's not going to be the mother of my children.
Yeah,
no,
she's not yet.
She's only told for other people.
If I split after her telling me this secret,
she'll feel like a piece of trash.
If you me like some puritan ass wipe.
My real reason for running away is you can't ask her to quit and if she does,
she'll only resent you for it and be at risk of relapsing any time I got to get
out.
How do I do it?
Well,
well,
what's you have to do is stop being concerned about her feelings.
What about your failings?
What about the fact that this woman is fucking around on you?
What about the fact that she could give you an STD?
What about the fact that she,
that relationship is built on trust and she has this giant fucking secret,
arguably the biggest fucking secret you could have.
You know,
I'm not judging anybody in this fucking story because I've been using when I've
been the whore,
I'm just it from the whore.
I except I except to get fight expected to get fucking dumped.
You know,
it's plenty of man or is out there,
you know?
That's what happens.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
you got to stop thinking about it.
Like,
it's weird.
Like this is what you have to do.
You,
you have to get over the,
um,
you have to be selfish in a fucking relationship to end up getting what you want
in life.
All right?
And you have to have parameters and you know,
to use the Cliche,
you know,
to make it home,
that you've got to break some eggs.
That's basically what you gotta do.
And this is not your fault.
Um,
I don't know what happened her that made her choose this horrific fucking
profession,
but it's not your fault and it's not your job to fix it.
And,
um,
you said it in your last two sentences.
I got to get out.
How do I do it?
Uh,
so I guess your second to last sentence you said it,
I got to get out.
So you just have,
you don't have to be mean about it.
You just have to say,
listen,
that's just a,
a unbelievable
piece of information you just gave me that you were keeping from me.
And uh,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
he's this guy.
You've got to use the Cliche,
you know,
relationships built on trust.
You know,
I'm not judging you.
I wish you weren't.
Maybe you know,
there's a part of her that might want,
is probably,
I don't even tell you this because you might run to this cause it's easier,
but like,
you know,
I dunno.
Well this is what I would do.
I would break up with her and then also try to get our help to get her out of
it.
That's what I would do.
And by getting her help,
I would give her information where she can go,
she needs to handle this on her own because you have feelings for her and you
know that this isn't the mother of your kids.
And if you just keep hanging around with her,
you're going to get sucked back into it again.
And now you have to trust somebody who lied to you at that fucking level.
And,
um,
that is just a fucking train wreck waiting to happen.
All right,
dude.
I would go get myself tested for everything on the under the fucking Sun.
And,
um,
that's it.
That's it.
And if she cries,
I mean,
that's part of it.
And she brought it on herself.
It's not your fault.
All right.
And I'm not trying to be mean or whatever.
I mean,
I don't know what happened to her that made her do that type of shit,
but that's not your fault.
Okay?
So why don't you go out there,
find a great girl who isn't a horror on the side and go live your dreams,
all right?
And you know what?
You're going to dump yard.
It's going to hurt for a little while,
even though you knew it was the right thing to do,
it's still supposed to hurt because you're a human being.
You just got to push through that.
Go to the gym right now of a couple of belts at the bar,
but just stay in it.
Stay in that pain and you wait to,
that pain's gone.
And then you fucking go out and try to find somebody else in the meantime,
you know,
rub one out.
All right?
Okay.
Ordain my wedding a bill.
I'm getting married in October.
Yes,
I'm getting in that line to lose half my shit.
Well,
Hey,
welcome to the club soda.
A strange request,
but would you ordain my wedding or at least be my best man?
Uh,
what is ordained me?
You want me to go,
dude,
we are gathered here his day to join these two people in holy matrimony and the
eyes of God planted the Church next to you.
You fucking busted aspirated tube.
The um,
yeah.
What kind of a man invites another man to a fucking wedding?
Don't ever do that to me again.
Okay.
I'll look past at one time.
Why the fuck would I want to go to a wedding?
You know,
actually,
you know what the reason why I didn't like to go to weddings in the past because
it put pressure on my relationship.
Now that we finally got married.
I,
there's no fucking pressure.
We're going to a marriage.
Marriage will go into a wedding coming up and I'm fucking site.
You know,
I,
I already
did it.
I don't have a fucking problem.
You sitting there eating fucking hors d'oeuvres,
dancing to the local motion,
whatever the fuck it is.
Just getting the habit.
I'm going to have a great fucking time for the first time.
You know what I might do you,
where is your wedding?
If I got a Gig in the area,
I got a Gig in the area,
I,
I might come over there.
Tell me where it is,
who knows?
Stranger things have happened.
But then if I two years,
then I got to do everybody right.
Can I sell my DVDs at the end of your wedding?
Try it.
A couple of bits.
Um,
anyways,
MIT master two shifts.
It's till technology creates toughest tongue twister.
Ever dare bill literate.
How you fucking cunt.
That's a great one.
Um,
thanks for the show.
You are amazing.
Look at this about this person is buttering me up to make a complete ass of me.
We all love the podcast and by far the best part is listening to you attempt to
reach spots and emails.
Yeah.
That's cause you're not happy or confident in your own life that you have to
watch somebody else fail.
That's what it is.
What does that say about it?
That's just more about you than it says about me.
All right,
you guys aren't my real friends.
Um,
MIT recently created what they think is the toughest tongue twister ever.
Give it a shot.
This is what they're doing at Mit.
I couldn't get accepted there.
If you can say it 10 times fast,
you get a price.
I'll go fuck yourself.
What am I at?
Goddamn dancing monkey.
What is it?
Pad Kid.
That's not even a,
well,
that doesn't even make sense.
Pad Kid poured curd pulled cod.
It shouldn't be that kid.
That kid poured curd pulled cod.
Yeah.
Pad Kid poured curd pulled cod.
Eh,
go fuck yourself.
Is this,
this is my actually saying something dirty and I can't hear it right now.
I don't fucking know.
All right.
For those of you who have absolutely no life,
if you want to fucking try and do that,
I,
you know,
have fun.
Okay.
Book recommendation.
Um,
what are we up to here?
Hour and seven minutes.
Beautiful.
Hey.
Hey Billy burgundy balls
heard.
You mentioned that no country for old men is one of your favorite movies.
Mine too.
If you're looking for any good books to read,
I highly recommend anything by Carmack McCarthy.
I hope I said that right.
Carmax,
c a r m a c one word.
Mccarthy,
m a lowercase c a R t.
H y author of no country.
Carmack McCarthy.
Oh,
he wrote that.
I actually want to read the book.
No country for old men.
Uh,
he said,
I read said book after I saw the movie.
And even though they did a great job with the movie,
the book was still incredible.
Everything I've read for him was top notch,
the border trilogy probably being my favorite.
If you hate easy going light on your low for stories with predictable happy
endings,
you'll dig his shit.
Come to Indianapolis and go,
fuck sir.
I came there last April.
Um,
all right.
You know what?
I will check that out.
I like him.
I make,
you know what I'm going to do.
You know what I'm going to do people,
I'm going to go to my website,
click on the podcast page,
and then I'm going to click on the Amazon banner in the corner,
which is gonna take me to Amazon because when you go to Amazon through us
here@billburr.com,
um,
it doesn't cost you any extra money,
costs you an extra click or your finger.
And,
um,
okay,
well,
you know,
whatever they,
you,
you know,
you buy whatever you buy and then they kick it back to me.
They give me a little bit of a kickback.
That's what they do.
And then I take that money and I give it to a charity that isn't corrupt,
hopefully like the last one I was giving to what should evidently,
and people saying is not exactly on the up and up.
So now I got to switch it to something else.
What kind of a fucking person does it and starts a goddamn charity.
Get show of fucking excited about it.
You think you'd make an,
you know,
and that's right up there with that pink lady,
man,
she's got her day in fucking,
something is coming.
I'd like to think.
I would like to thank.
Okay.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
I guess that's the podcast for this week.
Once again,
everybody check out the common threat clinic tour and uh,
all these guys are monster drummers and really unbelievable,
uh,
educators and drums.
And I'm telling you,
they've got websites,
they've got all kinds of stuff.
They got stuff to get your band's going and just all kinds of information was
phenomenal.
Um,
anyways,
that is the podcast for this this week.
I'm trying to think where am I going to be next?
Next thing I'm doing is I'm doing a a a casino gig in Minnesota on February 7th.
It's just outside of Minneapolis.
I have all the dates and other proper links up on my website,
[inaudible] dot com and once again,
I know I was given the people in Saskatchewan.
Shit,
I'm going to try to get out there.
Uh,
I really,
I absolutely blown away,
blown away by the response to me finally touring Canada up there and uh,
I'm going to be bringing the lumber.
All right,
so I'll see you guys in a couple of months.
I got a nice run,
a dates going through jersey,
down into Maryland and into Virginia also in February and we got the Patrice
O'neil is second annual.
I'm so proud to say that the second annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit on
February 18th in New York City.
It's already sold out.
But,
uh,
there aren't going to be ways that if you would like to contribute that we will
have.
I'm actually thinking about starting up an email where I can,
um,
you know,
get some more pictures of Patrice was maybe some,
some fan photos they took after.
I know he used to like going out and talking to people and uh,
I'm just really proud that we're doing it again this year,
helping out all the people that he was helping out.
And I'm keeping the memory of,
uh,
the
most amazing comic I ever saw live.
And that's not it.
That's not,
I probably then,
I'm not exaggerating like this guy,
you know,
anything I highly recommend,
any fucking thing that you can watch on youtube or download or anything by his
specials.
Uh,
if you have any sort of appreciation for comedy or just art in general.
He was,
he was the best.
He made all of us look like little kids.
So,
uh,
the second annual one,
and I,
I hope to be doing this for as long as I'm around is going to be on February
18th.
And like I said,
we will try to get some merged together.
We're trying to figure out what the fuck we're going to do for the fans that
couldn't make it there.
They're wanting to donate.
Um,
maybe have a donate button.
Maybe bill,
maybe you could just figure out what the fuck it is instead of trying to
brainstorm on your podcast.
All right,
go fuck yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.
Oh,
Superbowl prediction.
I said it last week and what to say it again this week?
I think,
uh,
Oh man,
I think I got to go with Seattle.
This something.
There's something about fucking Denver and how John Elway at the end of his
career solidified his name in history by fucking,
uh,
within those last two.
And now,
I don't know,
some weird that Peyton is playing for the Broncos.
That's the only thing that's making me nervous.
But I think the difference in the game is going to be Marshawn lynch.
And I think Denver is going to do a good job in the first half of doing,
you know,
the best you can to contain that unbelievable talent.
But I think that they get to wear him down.
I thought that Denver's defense looked a little,
I don't know if they were tired or what,
but I was not liking the fact if I'm a betting man,
the way they let San Diego in New England hang around even after they totally
fucking dominated them for the first two,
three quarters.
So I think Marshawn lynch is going to be the difference.
He's going to chew up some clock and a pig man.
He's going to be standing there on the sidelines with that look on his face.
Like he got to be fucking shitting me.
Not again.
Um,
but having said that,
I actually really liked both teams and um,
I actually all the Shit I've talked about Peyton over the years,
you know,
really sticking up for Brady made me not like Payton,
it's not like I know the guy.
I actually would love to see him win another one.
But I would also like to finally see Seattle's fans actually have something to
cheer about loudly,
like a championship as opposed to that with the best dressed where the most
spirited with allowed us to fucking horseshit that they've started.
And you did start that.
Okay.
So know that,
know that,
that you started that and when you see it in the future that it started in your
fucking coffee making God damn city.
Oh,
by the way,
did anybody see,
and this is why I don't like that Sherman talk and Shit fucking horseshit after
a game.
I really,
I,
I'm that old white guy that thinks it's absolutely classic,
classless.
Um,
can I say it right?
Classless and,
and just what it teaches children.
And I can tell you right now,
did anybody see that Justin Bieber video of him playing one on one with his
black friend that he paid to lose during the youtube video that anybody watched
that?
I can't even remember what the fuck I saw it.
I can't remember if it was on the news or if I watched it online,
but he sinks his shot.
He's filming himself.
He sinks his shot and he turns around and gives this look to the video camera is
he walks all the way back to take the ball out again.
If you see the look on this fucking hundred and 40 pound jack asses face and I
can't even get mad at him,
he learned it by watching these fucking idiots who hit layups and you know,
thought that chest and do that 300 fucking yell after everything that they do.
It's the dumbest
people literally fighting and wars like fucking Rambo taken out three people at
once.
After they do that,
they don't fucking turn around and give a look.
Why don't you hit a fucking the kid?
It's like a 10 foot turns around and he looks like he's like,
dislike it.
I never even saw Jordan do that.
He stared down some people,
absolutely.
But after what he dunked on Patrick Ewing and some other six foot 10 guy,
that's what I don't like about it.
And I see it just,
yeah,
the kids,
they learn it and then all of a sudden they're playing the fucking game and I
got to sit there and every time somebody hits a layup or catches a four yard
pass for a first down,
they got to act like they reinvented the game.
And I never saw Jerry Rice.
Wayne Gretzky.
I mean,
I've seen some magic Johnson.
I never saw do that.
Jesus Christ act like you fucking been there the before you goddamn idiots.
I,
I dunno.
I swear to God.
If everybody starts doing it,
I'm going to get into needlepoint.
All right.
You know what?
Maybe that'll call me down.
Maybe it'll help me with my fucking Tampa.
All right,
I'll talk to you next week.
Go Fuck Yourself.